alors conformément à ce qui est sorti
dans la presse nationale que sont des
informations qu'on met certaines chaînes
de télévision effectivement janet année
est actuellement au service du smpr de
la maison d'arrêt où il est incarcéré
c'est à dire qu'il est en milieu
médicalisé sous surveillance médicale
renforcée en raison notamment d'une
perte de poids massive
on l'a vu avec m spatafora dans un état
où il est physiquement je dirais
squelettiques un seul mot c'est comme ça
que je les ai vus très affaibli très
amoindri sous traitement aussi
manifestement d'un certain nombre de
psychotropes et autres avec des
difficultés importantes d'élocution il a
cessé de s'alimenter il a absolument pas
cessé de s'alimenter
personne ne s'explique cette perte de
poids massive
sachant que john atta était déjà un
homme assez sec physiquement et là on
est face à quelqu'un qui est une
maigreur extrême donc acquis et an est
préoccupante
c'est pris en charge bien évidemment par
la maison d'arrêt dans laquelle il est
détenu
puisque la direction portant soins et
une attention tout à fait particulière à
la situation de santé de jonah tant de
mal est ce que sa vie est en danger
en tout cas ça sans télé je n'irai pas
jusqu'à dire que sa vie est en danger je
suis pas médecin mais en tout cas il est
dans un état de santé qu'on peut
qualifier de préoccupant comment ça se
passe et ce qui va pouvoir rester dans
cette structure spécialisée de la maison
d'arrêt où est-ce qu'il va devoir en
sortir
très clairement il ya des analyses qui
sont en cours au niveau médical en
fonction du résultat de ses analyses
soit on va considérer que son état de
santé reste compatible avec sa détention
peut-elle qu'elle se passe aujourd'hui
au sein d'une maison d'arrêt équipé de
ce qu'on appelle un service smpr c'est
quoi l'intérêt c'est le service médico
psychologique régional c'est pas du tout
hein
gg lui et qu'il était interné en
psychiatrie n'est pas du tout interné en
psychiatrie n'est pas il a un suivi
psychiatrique bien sûr notamment pour
pouvoir dormir notamment pour pouvoir
gérer le trop plein d'émotion qu'il a
hélas des compensations qu'il est la
sienne depuis qu'il est incarcéré
ça c'est très habituel d'ailleurs en la
matière en matière criminelle mais si
son état de santé se dégrade on verra à
ce moment-là ce qui sera plus opportun
de le faire parce que le maison d'arrêt
est équipé pour pour certaines
pathologies et certaines difficultés de
santé à partir moment elles ne sont pas
extrêmes vous évoquez son état
psychologique pourrait presque dire
psychiatrique c'est en tout cas pas une
situation qui peut être utilisée pour le
faire pas assumer les actes qu'il a qui
l'a reconnu c'est ce que nous avons vu
aussi au travers de certaines
certains médias et certains réseaux
sociaux aucune stratégie là dedans c'est
son état de santé et se dégrade
on n'a jamais parlé d'infirmité ou de
maladies mentales concernant que jo
d'athènes d'amal c'est un garçon tout à
fait sain de corps et d'esprit qui se
trouve avec des problèmes de santé liés
à son incarcération est liée à ça des
compensations il n'est en aucun cas
question sous-entendu une question sur
les responsabilités de johnatan il
appartiendra aux psychiatres de
s'exprimer sur ce point la vente ces
quatre experts judiciaires et en aucun
cas ce n'est sous entendus aujourd'hui
par la défense de la navale ces
conditions de détention depuis son
incarcération il côtoie d'autres détenus
il est isolé comment ça se passe
johnatan d'avaldsnes a côtoyé depuis son
incarcération personne en dehors de
quelques personnels de l'administration
pénitentiaire
il est seul ce qui est aussi compliqué à
gérer pour l'instant il n'a pas eu accès
à sa famille que ce soit par téléphone
ou dans le cadre d'un parloir familial
ce qui est une souffrance importante
pour lui puisqu'il a vraiment besoin
je suis vraiment besoin de voir sa mère
c'est la seule revendication qu'il a il
en a pas d'autre et effectivement ils ne
parlent à personne
donc vous comprenez que c'est difficile
d'être totalement isolé le comprends
c'est pour sa sécurité
mais ce qui est le plus difficile aussi
c'est de gérer le sommeil et de gérer la
nuit parce que déjà quand vous êtes seul
la journée et des activités qui vous
éloigne qui repose un peu l'esprit mais
la nuit il n'y a rien et donc la nuit à
part la souffrance psychologique
visiblement dont certains gardiens de
prisons parle il n'y a strictement rien
en dehors d'une un cerveau qui
fonctionne en boucle la nuit elle ne
dort pas moi ce que j'en sais c'est que
il a très peu de sommeil